l'enquêté sur la mort du petit grégory
n'a guère avancé ces dernières 24 heures
depuis la diffusion du nouveau portrait
robot établi par les policiers
seul fait nouveau les parents du petit
garçon retrouvé assassiné dans la
vologne
ses parents se sont portés parties
civiles après avoir choisi leur avocat
maître garraud qui est aussi l'avocat de
l'association légitime défense sur place
isabelle bechler à la gendarmerie de
bruz hier les enquêteurs continuent leur
travail de fourmi mais sans résultat
concluant
seule communication à la presse cette
affichette manuscrite qui avoue que l'
enquête ne progresse que très peu ce
matin les parents de grégory qui se sont
constitués parties civiles ont vu leur
avocat chez le juge
un choix qui peut surprendre m au garrot
a plaidé à plusieurs reprises pour
légitime défense
je lui dis plaide par exemple pour
patrick henry il est comparable à
batterie gorille je ne peux qu'espérer
que cette raison qu'ils ont fait du tout
mais vraiment je vends un sentiment de
vengeance quand il tente où les gens
tout le village ont prévu se donnèrent
les mondes vengeance il s'agit d'un
sentiment d'injustice trouver l'assassin
ça me paraît la justice normale
naturelle
je pense qu'après un honnête homme qui
ne veulent pas qu'on découvre l'assassin
celui qui a tué sept enfants
voilà mon sentiment les parents de
grégory ne nous ont pas expliqué le
choix de leurs avocats il s'agit pour
eux avant tout d'avoir accès au dossier
de l'instruction